foreign
let's go to uh Joel in Houston hi Joel
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Ramsey how you doing better than we
deserve how can Dr John and I help
well thank you so much for taking me on
um but see I'm calling you today this is
because I'm very nervous about the new
student loan payments resuming and
everything
um
so I'm 24 years old you know I make
sixty thousand dollars a year and I am
soon to be married so I'm currently
engaged congratulations
thank you sir thank you appreciate it
um what do you do yeah so
um I am a so I work in logistics uh
Transportation Logistics you got a
supply chain to Green you make 60 Grand
yes sir well that sucks you need to make
more than that you're probably worth 80.
I'm working towards it yet it took a
while to get to 60. no I'm telling you
dude the marketplace right now is about
80 for a newly graduated I mean you got
a four-year degree in supply chain
yes sir okay yeah you're underpaid I'll
just tell you you need to go look at
anyway what how much student loan debt
have you got
uh so I have about 30 000 on a car you
know thirty thousand Joel
and you make sixty okay how much is your
student loan debt
18K okay and and your fiancee what's she
do
uh she works for
um
a government facility it's such a
children's Assessment Center
um you know they need to take care of
children what'd she make
whatever
um she makes 19 an hour
and she has a four-year degree
yes criminal justice okay
okay uh the two of you are vastly
underpaid so we're going to work on your
careers for sure
um you bought a car you can't afford sir
the car is in cray-cray land
Nutty Nutty Thirty a sixty thousand
dollar car you make I mean you make 60
and you have a thirty thousand dollar
car that doesn't work so you don't have
a student loan problem you got a car
problem
yeah nervous laugh means you're gonna
keep it what's that mean unless dude I I
drove the street to Houston that's where
I grew up in a 1988 turcell easy
hatchback a thousand bucks you don't
need a forty thousand dollar car when
you're broke
that is true it was just an emergency I
had no no it's not a 30 000 emergency no
it wasn't the beer just fell in my mouth
officer no you bought it
okay man uh nervous laughs aside the
number one mistake newly minted college
graduates make is they go buy a car they
can't afford so you're not dumb you just
did what most college graduates do you
went and bought a car you can't afford
and if you don't hear this loud and
clear it's going to hold you back
because if you didn't have a what 650
car payment making sixty thousand you
wouldn't be calling me about the student
loan debt
so if I woke up in your shoes if you
were my son and you call me my nephew
and you called me and you said I'm
getting ready to get married Papa Dave
uh what should I do to get ready to have
a great life with this woman I'm in love
with I would say work on your career
you're underpaid you're worth more than
you think you're worth in the
marketplace today you're a stud supply
chain is an excellent degree field way
to go good choice and you bought a car
that indicates you were doing drugs so
stop doing this stop stop stop get rid
this would be Papa Dave talking to my
nephew I'd be going you're out of
control dude you got to sell it so the
best thing you can do for the future
Joel and the future Joel's wife is to
get rid of this car and get you a beater
and get rid of student loans as fast as
you can by living on beans and rice rice
and beans and work on your career choice
and she needs to work on hers you go get
a four-year degree to make 19 you can
make 19 at Target if you didn't even get
out of high school so
um that that's just ridiculous she again
you both have have accepted positions
and you've somehow Justified or
rationalized it that you're you're both
worth more than you have been so far but
it's time time to work on those two
areas if I were you that's what I would
do yeah my dad's a criminal justice
Professor I know that's underpaid I know
that's too low and there's a number of
things you can do across that that far
yeah a whole bunch of stuff you can do
with current criminal justice but but
that's not 19 right so I mean and by the
way that's that's the that's when when
we say that that's when she says well I
really love work with these kids so I
get that yeah I get that
but right now you can't afford to do
follow your heart or do your passion
thing or whatever Instagram's telling
you to do because you got y'all got
bills quit your job I'm working with a
youth group of the church but that
doesn't make sense I mean he does to pay
right you did work with youth group of
children work a job but that's how you
do that you do both you know you can't
mix the two up and be underpaid it
doesn't work so hey man we're gonna put
you guys through Financial Peace
University as our wedding gift hold on
Austin's gonna pick up and uh we were
messing with you pretty hard but if you
listen to what we said it's going to
help you